This is breaking. In big news,
Israel has carried out large air strikes against Iran.
Attacking Iran.
This is bad and reckless behavior
because Israel already knew ahead of time
that this had the possibility of leading to World War 3.
With all the threats and alliances beforehand,
Iran has already promised immediate and maximum response.
And we will see where this goes.
Joe Biden has promised that America will not participate in the attack
I with Iran if Israel attacks.
And Joe Biden better stick to his promises,
cause we will not send any of our sons and daughters,
any of our soldiers to die in Israel's wars.
They chose to do this on their own
and they can suffer the consequences of a period
we should not even help in defense.
This is absolutely reckless and terrible behavior.
Israel is intentionally trying to push everybody else into war,
and we need to abandon them as an ally before they involve us.